THANKS FOR JOINING US, THE ERASE
OF UKRAINE'S GAINS, THE RATE HAS
BEEN PICKING UP.
IT'S STRIKING, HAPPENING ALL
ACROSS SEVERAL REGIONS AS WE
TAKE ANOTHER BROAD LOOK OF THE
MAP.
THIS IS ALL IN A FEW SHORT
WEENGS.
THIS WAS AGAINST RUSSIA'S
TRAINED MILITARY.
MORE
WILL MORE NUMBERS ONCE THINGS
ARE DONE MAKE A DIFFERENCE?
>> PUTIN HAS FAILED IN HIS
EFFORTS.
I THINK UKRAINIANS HAVE DEVELOP
ED WELL PLANT INITIATIVES TO THE
EAST AS WELL AS THE SOUTH.
THERE'S A MULTIPLE PRONGED
INITIATIVE THAT'S GOING ON HERE.
THE RUSSIANS, FRANKLY RRK NOT
STANDING UP.
THEY'RE BASICALLY DEPLETED.
AND THEY'RE FALLING BACK.
SO I THINK WE ARE LOOKING AT
CLEARLY A CONTINUING EFFORT BY
UKRAINE TO PUSH THE RUSSIANS OUT
OF THEIR COUNTRY.
>> HOW IMPORTANT IS THE TIMING
OF THESE UKRAINIAN ADVANCES?
UP HERE, DOWN HERE IN THE SOUTH.
ESPECIALLY BEFORE WINTER WHEN
THE BATTLEFIELD WILL LITERALLY
CHANGE?
>> I THINK IT'S EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT RUSSIA JUST WENT
THROUGH THE ACT OF PRETENDING TO
ANNEX THOSE AREAS, NOW
APPOINTING NEW HEADS OF THOSE
VARIOUS AREAS, BUT THE BOTTOM
LINE IS THEY'RE NOT IN CONTROL.
THEY'RE NOT IN CONTROL.
EVEN THOUGH THEIR FORCES ARE
DEPLETED NOW AND THEY DO HAVE
THE POSSIBILITY OF TRYING TO
APPLY SOME OF THEIR NEWLY
MOBILIZED FORCES, I THINK THE
PROBLEM IS THEY'RE FAILING AT
THIS AS WELL.
THEY'RE FIGHTING A TWO-FRONT WAR
NOT ONLY IN UKRAINE BUT IN
RUSSIA.
THEY'RE FINDING IT VERY
DIFFICULT TO BE ABLE TO
IMMOBILIZE INDIVIDUALS, AND
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT TRAINING
THEM BY PUTTING THEM ON A
SHOOTING RANGE FOR A LITTLE
WHILE AND THROWING THEM INTO
COMBAT.
THEY WILL NOT BE PROPERLY
PREPARED FOR COMBAT.
SO I THINK UKRAINE HAS A CLEAR
ADVANTAGE RIGHT NOW IN TERMS OF
THIS WAR.
>> ZELENSKYY SAYS UKRAINE WILL
NOT STOP UNTIL IT RETAKES ALL OF
UKRAINIAN LAND INCLUDING CRY ME
A YA, WHICH WAS ANNEXED IN 2014.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
IS CRIMEA IN PLAY HERE?
>> I THINK PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY
IS THE ONE TO MAKE THAT
DECISION.
IT IS HIS COUNTRY.
UKRAINE DID CONSIST OF CRIMEA AS
WELL AS THE OTHERARY YAS RUSSIA
IS NOW CLAIMING PART OF RUSSIA.
WE KNOW UKRAINE HAS PUT UP A
VERY COURAGEOUS FIGHT FOR THEIR
COUNTRY, AND THEY'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO DO I.
I THINK THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT
UKRAINE HAS THE ADVANTAGE NOW.
BUT WE ALSO SHOULDN'T KID
OURSELVES.
THERE'S PROBABLY A LOT OF
FIGHTING THAT STILL REMAINS.
SOME OF THESE AREAS ARE GOING TO
BE MORE DIFFICULT.
BUT RIGHT NOW THERE'S NO
QUESTION THEY HAVE THE
ADVANTAGE.
>> IS THISERE A SCENARIO WHERE
PUTIN CAN LOSE THE WAR BUT STAY
IN POWER?
>> I DO NOT SEE PUTIN BEING ABLE
TO REMAIN IN POWER UNLESS HE CAN
CLAIM SOME KIND OF PHONY VI
VICTORY.
THIS WOULD MEAN HE WOULD HAVE TO
TAKE AN OFF-RA HFOFF-RAMP.
MY SENSE IS PUTIN IS NOT WILLING
TO NEGOTIATE AT THIS POINT.
MY INTELLIGENCE FRIENDS ALL MAKE
CLEAR PUTIN WILL CONTINUE TO
DOUBLE DOWN , AND ULTIMATELY WHT
THAT MEANS IS WE'RE STILL GOING
TO HAVE A PROLONGED WAR IN
UKRAINE.
HOPEFULLY UKRAINIANS CAN PUSH
THE RUGS OUT OF UKRAINE.
THAT'S PRIMARILY THE GOAL RIGHT
NOW.
>> WOULD PUTIN ACCEPT DEFEAT OR
BEING BURNED BACK?
I THINK IN THE BEHALF EVERLE IN.
WHAT CAN HAPPEN IF HE'S FORCED
TO DO?
MORE DRASTIC?
WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE?
ARE YOU WORRIED ABOUT NOOKS?
>> LOOK, THERE'S ONLY ONE THING
PUTIN UNDERSTANDS.
HE'S NOT SOMEBODY WHO'S
INTERESTED IN DIPLOMACY OR
NEGOT
NEGOTIATION.
THE ONLY WAY TO DEAL WITH PUTIN
IS BY FORCE, AND THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT UKRAINIANS ARE DOING.
WHICH MEANS THEY'RE GOING TO TRY
TO CONTINUE THISSER OF THE TRY
TO PUSH THE RUGS OW.
HE HAS TO MAKE THE DECISION
WHETHER HE'S GOING FIND SOME SIM
LANCE OR WHETHER HE'S GOING TO
BE DEFEATED.
IF HE IS TOTALLY DEFEATED, I
DON'T SEE ANY E WAY PUTIN CAN
SURVIVE.
THE REAL QUESTION IS WHETHER HE
WANTS TO SURVIVE OR ULTIMATELY
END HIS REGIME.
>> THIS COMING FROM A MAN WHO
HAS MET.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TIME.
OUR CORRESPONDENT CNN FREDERICK
PLANKTON IS IN CNN'S CAPITOL.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU WITH, THE
SPREAD.
UKRAINE FORCES ARE CERTAINLY
PUSHING AHEAD WITH A COUNTER
OFFENSIVE RUSSIAN FORCES
SEEMING, ON THE VERGE OF
COLLAPSE.
SHOULD UKRAINE TAKE THAT BACK?
WHAT WOULD IT MEAN?
WHAT A SHIFT THE MOMENTUM
FURTHER?
>> I THINK IT WOULD DEFINITELY
SHIFT THE MOMENTUM FURTHER.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING RIGHT NOW IS
ALREADY A HUGE SHIFT IN
MOMENTUM.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE HAVE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT OVER THE
PAST TWO, TWO AND A HALF MONTHS
IS A SMALL UKRAINIAN COUNTER
OFFENSIVE IN SOME SMALLER
POCKETS OF THE FRONTLINE.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING RIGHT NOW IS
UKRAINIAN COUNTER OFFENSE IS IN
LARGE PARTS OF THE AREAS WHERE
THE RUSSIAN FORCES AND
UKRAINIANS MEET ON THE FRONT
LINE.
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT THE EAST
AND THE SOUTH AS WELL.
IF YOU LOOK AT THAT MAP IN
FRONT OF US, THERE IS REALLY
LARGE AREAS WHERE THE UKRAINIAN
FORCES ARE ADVANCING.
FOR INSTANCE, WE HAVE BEEN
TALKING IN THE PAST COUPLE DAYS
ABOUT THE TOWN OF LYMAN, WHICH
WAS A REALLY IMPORTANT LOGISTIC
HUB FOR THE RUSSIANS.
UKRAINIANS HAVE TAKEN THAT BACK
AND HAVE NOW MANAGED TO PUSH ON
SEVERAL KILOMETERS FROM THERE.
THEY HAVE SAID TO TAKE OVER
OTHER AREAS THERE WHICH
OBVIOUSLY, ON THE ONE HAND,
MAKES IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR THE
RUSSIANS TO CONDUCT THEIR OWN
LOGISTICS BECAUSE A LOT OF
THEIR LOGISTICS ARE NOW WITHIN
ARTILLERY RANGE OF THE
UKRAINIANS.
ALSO OBVIOUSLY IT ALLOWS
UKRAINIANS TO PUSH FURTHER
TOWARDS THOSE RUSSIAN DEFENSIVE
LINES.
A BIG STORY, I THINK THE ONE
THAT HAS BEEN REALLY SURPRISING
FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE HAS BEEN
THE ONE IN THE SOUTH WHERE LATE
LAST NIGHT THE UKRAINIANS WERE
SAYING THAT THEY WERE MAKING
HUGE GAINS IN THAT AREA WINNING
BACK A LOT A VERY IMPORTANT
VILLAGES AND TOWNS AS THEY TRY
TO MOVE FURTHER SOUTH TOWARDS
THAT TOWN WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY A
VERY IMPORTANT ONE.
LINDA, ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE ALSO HAVE TO MENTION IS THAT
THE RUSSIANS ARE STILL SHOOTING
BACK.
ONE THING THAT HAPPENED
OVERNIGHT HERE IS THAT THE
RUSSIANS USED KAMIKAZE DRONES,
THE UKRAINIANS SAY, POSSIBLY
SUPPLIED BY IRAN TO HIT AN AREA
OR A TOWN THAT IS ONLY ABOUT 50
MILES FROM WHERE I AM RIGHT NOW.
THAT CAUSED HUGE DAMAGE THERE
IN SOME AREAS OF THE PLACE.
CERTAINLY STILL A VERY
DANGEROUS CONFLICT BUT RIGHT
NOW THE UKRAINIANS CLEARLY
BELIEVE THAT THE MOMENTUM IS ON
THEIR SIDE.
>> FRED, IT'S CERTAINLY
INTERESTING WHEN YOU HEAR FROM
MOSCOW OFFICIALS WHO ADMIT THEY
STILL ARE NOT SURE WHERE THE
BORDERS ARE IN THESE REGIONS
THAT THEY HAVE CLAIM TO
ILLEGALLY ANNEX.
ALSO EIGHT MONTHS INTO THE WAR
WE HAVE HEARD FROM A TOP
RUSSIAN WAR CORRESPONDENT WHO
IS NOW ACKNOWLEDGING THE LOSSES.
>> CERTAINLY.
IT'S REALLY A SHIFT IN THE
RHETORIC THAT WE ARE SEEING
ESPECIALLY ON RUSSIAN STATE TV.
I HAVE BEEN WATCHING A LOT OF
IT OVER THE PAST COUPLE OF
MONTHS SINCE ALL OF THIS HAS
BEEN GOING ON.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE HAVE
ALWAYS HEARD WAS ABOUT RUSSIAN
ADVANCES AND HOW WELL THEY ARE
DOING HERE IN UKRAINE.
THAT IS CERTAINLY SEEMING TO BE
A LOT MORE MUTED NOW.
THAT CORRESPONDED AND SOME
OTHER PEOPLE AS WELL ON
GOVERNMENT TV.
SOME HOSTS ALSO TALKING ABOUT
THE FACT THAT IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT FOR THE RUSSIANS ON
THE FRONTLINES, ON THE
BATTLEFIELD AND ALSO SAYING
THAT THE MOBILIZATION THAT HAS
TAKEN PLACE SO FAR BY THE
RUSSIANS, THE DEFENSE MINISTER
OF COURSE SAYING THAT THEY
MOBILIZED AROUND 200,000 PEOPLE
TO TAKE PART IN THE RUSSIAN
ARMED FORCES.
THAT IS NOT GOING TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN THE BATTLEFIELD
UNTIL AT LEAST A COUPLE OF
WEEKS FROM NOW, IF NOT MORE
THAN THAT.
CERTAINLY THEY ARE
ACKNOWLEDGING IT'S A VERY
DIFFICULT SITUATION BUT I THINK
ONE OF THE OTHER THINGS THAT
YOU JUST SAID IS ALSO WARY MORE
REMARKABLE AS WELL.
THE RUSSIANS, SO FAR, HAS NOT
SAID WHAT EXACTLY THE BORDERS
OF THESE ANNEXED TERRITORIES
THAT THEY CLAIMED TO HAVE
ANNEXED, WITH THE BORDERS OF
THOSE ARE GOING TO BE.
IT WAS INTERESTING BECAUSE CNN
ACTUALLY ASKED THE SPOKESMAN
FOR THE KREMLIN TODAY AND HE
SAID HE WOULD LEAVE THAT
QUESTION UNANSWERED FOR NOW
THAT HE DOES BELIEVE THE
RUSSIANS WILL BE ABLE TO TAKE
SOME OF THE TERRITORY BACK BUT
RIGHT NOW THINGS CERTAINLY SEEM
TO BE GOING IN THE OTHER
DIRECTION.